greetings everyone good afternoon my
name is David Bob I am director of the
Kirby Center Hillsdale College we're
pleased that you're joining us here on
Capitol Hill and across the country via
webcast today we're pleased to feature a
most important topic taught by one of
the foremost experts on the matter of
religious freedom blasphemy and free
speech is the title of Paul Marshalls
remarks and we're pleased that you've
joined us to consider this most relevant
and timely topic we'll have time for
questions both in person and those of
you who are from around the country
shortly after the prepared remarks this
morning I'll have some announcements at
the end of our time together today and I
think for those of you who are regular
attendees of this first principles on
First Fridays lecture series you know
that lunch follows the forum so we'll
ask invite you all to join again today
in that to offer a formal introduction
of our speaker is Hillsdale College
senior Emily Reagan and when a politics
major is interning at the Heritage
Foundation this term Emily please it's
my pleasure to introduce our speaker for
today Paul Marshall is a senior fellow
at the Hudson Institute Center for
religious freedom he's written for The
Wall Street Journal and The New York
Times and is the author or editor of
more than 20 books on religion and
politics including their blood cries out
blind spot when journalists don't get
religion and most recently silence how
apostasy and blasphemy codes are choking
freedom worldwide today he will be
discussing the important topic blasphemy
and free speech so please join me in
welcoming mr. Paul Marshall
thank you very much for that kind
introduction and thank you very much to
Hillsdale for having me here I've long
been a fan of Hillsdale College having
been out to Michigan I once spoke on a
program with the Dalai Lama Dalai Lama
is a younger brother who gave insights
about not in public but in over coffee
insights about the Dalai Lama you
wouldn't get anywhere else except you
know nobody's a hero to his younger
brother but it's it's very good to be
here I've got my topic is blasphemy and
free speech and there are many aspects
to this but I'm going to focus on the
question of blasphemy within the context
of Islam which is 99% of the cases were
dealing with worldwide right now I'm
going to use the term blasphemy
occasionally apostasy occasionally
insulting religion that shorthand for a
whole family of terms if you try to look
at blasphemy laws worldwide it often
wouldn't reveal much because the various
offenses can be described as defamation
of Islam causing confusion to Muslims
creating anxiety amongst the leaders of
the Islamic Republic that is an offense
in Iran it would be a virtue in the
United States warring against God
friendship with the enemies of God
deviating from true religion insulting a
heaven religion there are very many of
these and many are not listed in statute
it is this family of restrictions that I
am interested in and for shorthand I'm
going to refer to this as as blasphemy
in the context of Islam in the Muslim
majority world and also in the West
twenty years ago it would probably have
seemed strange to pick a topic such as
this there are blasphemy laws still on
the books in the West but mo
the defunct at the federal level the
United States has never had a blasphemy
law and so it would seem to many an
archaic subject that changed 20 years
ago in 1989 the supreme leader of the
Islamic Republic of Iran the late
Ayatollah Khomeini issued a fatwa which
declared that a book a novel The Satanic
Verses by a British based Indian origin
author Salman Rushdie was blasphemous
and therefore it was the duty of every
Muslim to kill Rushdie and others
involved in that book as you would know
Rushdie is still alive but he has had to
live they protected and hidden life ever
since others have not been so fortunate
the novel's Japanese translator was
assassinated it's Italian translator was
stabbed it's Norwegian publisher was
shot thirty-five guests at a Turkish
hotel hosting its its Turkish publisher
were burned to death in an arson attack
several hundreds of people died as a
result of that this decree by Khomeini
inaugurated the export of blasphemy
rules to the West that is seeking to
hold people in the West including the
United States also subject to those
types of restrictions so what I will do
is review much of what is happening in
the Muslim world and then the attempted
export of these to the West but since
her manias edict the 21st century has
was witness repeated interruption
eruptions of violence worldwide for
example in regard to teo van gogh and
ayaan Hirsi Ali xemnas film submission
Jo van Gogh was of course killed on a
street in Amsterdam his killer was
attempting to behead him when he was
apprehended you had the famous Danish
cartoons in yellow and Poston the
Swedish cartoons Pope Benedict's
Regensburg speech on reason
violence in religion which produced and
which resulted in an eruption of
violence hate builders film fitna the
force newsweek story that the US
military desecrated Kurans
such matters are in the news every now
every week pretty well every day some
events such as the decoration by terry
jones are deservedly obscure florida
pasta with a congregation of less than
fifty his decoration that he would burn
a Koran during prime time on September
the 11th 2010 achieved a perfect media
storm it combined Muslim outraged at the
desecration of the Koran with American
public publicity-seeking and also the
demands of a 24-hour news coverage this
claim which he did not carry out at that
point drew in the military commander of
the US forces in Afghanistan the
Secretary of Defense the Secretary of
State and the President of the United
States all for a man who simply said he
was going to burn a Koran why is this
become such an issue for us well one
reason these issues have grown the way
they do is that there is deliberate
manipulation of these sentiments by many
governments around the world okay the
campaign's about insulting Islam are not
often about callous cartoonists or
provocative pastors but in in reaction
to particular policy goals of
governments which take a very real
resentment and stoke it for example the
famous Danish cartoons of Muhammad were
published in Denmark's largest newspaper
Yale and Poston in September 2005 what
erupted when they came out nothing
there were peaceful demonstrations by
Muslims in Denmark complaining about
this which I have every right to do so
but in December of that year the
organisation of Islamic Conference now
called the organisation of the Islamic
Cooperation the OIC held its meeting in
in Mecca and changed its agenda to
discuss the cartoons and government's
sought to call attention to them that
was December that was three months later
the violence erupted in February 2006
five months after the caricatures were
published Saudi Arabia and Egypt
perhaps irritated by the then US policy
of pushing for democracy in the Middle
East
urged boycotts of Danish products Iran
and Syria manipulated riots partly to
defect deflect attention from their
nuclear projects
Denmark was do in fact assure the UN
nuclear disarmament committee beginning
that April turkey lady used the cartoons
as bargaining chips in negotiation
through the US including in person with
President Obama to gain leverage for two
high-level Turkish appointments to NATO
so there are many how is it that 98
percent of Egyptians and 99% of Syrians
knew about these cartoons the press is
controlled the people who could not find
Denmark on a map you all about or
thought they knew all about these gotten
these cartoons in contrast you probably
have not heard of Lars Vilks
Swedish cartoons which unlike the Danish
ones are sort of meant to be offensive
when Vilks published those again what
happened almost nothing there are still
repeated attempts to assassinate him but
no government made a fuss about it and
then when Terry Jones actually did burn
a Koran do you know that he did so
several months ago what happened then
almost nothing I think our media helped
they realized that giving great coverage
this increases the chance it's going to
happen but we have a situation that that
some situations erupt others which one
would expect too
cause far more reaction do not hence one
of the first points I want to make is
that campaigns against insults to Islam
are not simply eruptions of outrageous
religious feeling they also reflect
governmental manipulation now I don't
mean that there is no religious feeling
that Muslims are not upset when people
burn a Koran the sense would be similar
if someone desecrated a house for a
Catholic Mass the sentiment is is very
real but it is channeled and again you
can only channel religious resentment or
religious outrage if it already exists
so the outrage is real but it is subject
to manipulation and we need to be aware
of that who tend to be the targets of
such accusations I've so far talked
about things in the West but most of the
targets are in the Muslim world as Nina
Shea and I show in a recent book
silenced on a bus apostasy and blasphemy
codes such accusations are now used
systematically in much of the Muslim
world to quash religious minorities but
also Muslim authors journalists
democracy activists including the
region's Nobel Prize winners the victims
also includes clued religious reformers
who may be jailed or killed by
vigilantes or terrorists for insulting
Islam or mocking religion amongst
religious minorities currently millions
of Baha'is and our Mahdi's followers of
religions or interpretations that arose
after Islam are condemned on mass as de
facto insulters of islam and a subject
of brutal and discriminatory laws
pervasive state and extralegal violence
and attacks by terrorists and vigilantes
the the leadership of Iran's 300,000
strong Baha'i community are currently
in prison and it in since Baha'is are
not recognized in Iran they have no
legal status which means there's no
penalty in that country for killing the
Baha'i they are literally outside the
law
our Mahdi's of whom there are several
million in Pakistan and millions
elsewhere suffer similar treatment in
fact if you go to the website of the
Pakistani embassy in Washington DC and
go to the forms which you need to fill
out to get a passport and you will come
to the requisite page when you must
denounce the ahmadis and affirm that
they are not muslims though they're
called caddy arnie's though you only
have to do this if you're a Muslim if
you're a Christian Pakistani or a Hindu
Pakistani you don't actually have to
denounce them but it is a condition for
getting a passport that you condemn the
on a Pakistani passport you condemn the
ahmadies those who leave Islam for
another religion or non face similar
fates most strikingly in Somalia the
al-shabaab militias are systematically
hunting down and killing every Christian
in the country on the grounds that all
Somalis used to be Muslims therefore if
one is a Christian they have left Islam
they are an apostate and the death
penalty applies this situation is not
covered in our media but it is a
campaign to literally exterminate
Christianity in those areas in mob
violence for example in 2009 after
allegations in Pakistan that the Koran
had been torn a 1,000 strong mob rampage
through Christian neighborhoods in
Punjab killing seven people burning them
alive that included two children police
were there but did not intervene or
amongst Muslims Sunnis Shia Sufis may
also be persecuted if they are in an
area dominated by another branch of
Islam Iran represses Sunnis and Sufism
Saudi Arabia represses year
as does Egypt where you can be
imprisoned for being under the influence
of Shia ideas but one major target on
which I want to focus relatively more
attention is Muslim reformers that is
people who by and large are interested
in religious freedom in political
freedom in freedom of speech and many
other things these are often the victims
of repression that accusations of
blasphemy are used by repressive regimes
and movements to silence their more
liberal by liberal I mean committed to
freedom their more liberal counterparts
so for example in Afghanistan Ali Maha
Tecna Saab the editor of women's rights
magazine was imprisoned by the Karzai
government for publishing Una's lamech
articles that criticized the idea
basically asked is Islam really requires
to stone adulterous or at least female
adulterers does it require us to kill
people who leave Islam for that he was
sentenced to prison in Saudi Arabia
democracy activists have been imprisoned
for using what the charge called an
Islamic terminology such as democracy
and human rights or Muhammad Yunus shake
a member of Paquette was a member of
Pakistan's Human Rights Commission when
he raised questions about Pakistan's
policy in Kashmir he was charged
following day with having blasphemes in
class in Bangladesh salahuddin salary
was imprisoned for hurting religious
feelings because he advocated peaceful
relations between Bangladesh and Israel
in Iran Ayatollah by Richard II was
imprisoned for arguing that political
leadership by clergy was contrary to
Islam which by the way is the
traditional Shia position Khomeini was
the unusual one or again in Iran though
there are many dissident ayatollahs
several of whom have been imprisoned
Mohsen cadaver was imprisoned after he
wrote a dense three-volume
theories of the state in shia
jurisprudence which book argued that the
late ayatollah khomeini's teaching of
the guardianship of the jurist was
contrary to shiite legal theory which
would be the view of most traditional
shiite scholars so he's put in prison
why deviating from true islam this man
is a pious Muslim this is a dense
traditional work in Shia jurisprudence
but it went against the policy of the
regime so he has put them still
continuing on the repression of Muslims
under these laws these threats even
exist or do exist against Muslims in the
West in 2006 an organization which
called itself the supporters of God's
messenger emailed 30 Muslim reformers
living in the West some of them friends
of mine said it would kill they said
they were apostate because of their
views and it would kill them unless they
repent they those who receive these
included the Egyptian Saturday nee
brahim perhaps the best-known human
rights activist in the Arab world has
been teaching in the United States
armored man sue who had been imprisoned
in Egypt for arguing against the death
penalty for apostasy these messages
included their addresses and the names
of their children so they were taken
seriously so these are Muslim reformers
living in the United States or in Europe
Mamoon post lockup a Belgian senator and
Muslim Belgian senator was forced into
hiding after threats to ritually
slaughter her because of her criticism
of the status of women in Belgian Muslim
communities a Candela goes the first
Muslim Member of Parliament and in in
Germany received death threats and lives
under police protection after she called
from Muslim women to take off the
headscarf
so these threats also extend against
Muslims in the West we could give many
more examples and then there is the
effort led by the Organization of
Islamic Cooperation the OIC to export
these laws
and they've sought to do so through the
UN for over 20 years calling for
international law to ban insulting Islam
or insulting religion and then
pressuring Western governments to
repress their own citizens when they say
something which is understood to be
insulting to Islam by somebody so and
many Western governments have in fact
caved in the face of this or resurrected
their own hate speech laws so in Austria
late last year
Elizabeth Savatage Wolfe was convicted
of denigrating religious beliefs for her
comments about Muhammad these were not
even sort of quote hate speech comments
about Muslims but it was in fact a
theological point she made she has been
fined in Austria she said she will not
pay and they can imprison them or
something a let me discuss a someone
who's currently a visiting faculty
member at Hillsdale College this year
mark Stein karen has grossly miss named
human rights commission's it have
interrogated writers including mark
Stein about their writings on Islam in
Europe popular politicians such as pet
builders ano see how a low in Finland
have been prosecuted for their comments
in political speeches on Islam these are
two of the most popular politicians in
their respective countries and these
were political speeches and then the
prosecutor comes calling if we turn to
the United States in America the First
Amendment still protects us from
criminalizing criticism of things
Islamic and despite the vagaries of our
courts in other areas they do tend to
hold up on this matter but in the United
States we still face at least two
dangers one is extra outside
intimidation outside of the law and I
should add that even in the Muslim world
this is the one which creates the most
victims in Pakistan the blasphemy laws -
two categories of blasphemy carry the
death penalty but nobody's been executed
but dozens and dozens of people have
been killed after being accused and in
the West this type of extra legal
intimidation as you get in Europe is
also a factor some examples of this in
2009 Yale University Press published the
definitive book on the Danish cartoon
crisis by ETA Claussen part of the
agreement with her was that they would
in the book include illustrations one of
which was to be a photograph of the page
of the cartoonist from from Yale and
post not each individual cartoon large
but just you know one page with so a
whole newspaper page with these things
that is this is a book about these let's
show them what the book is about and
there were also so Yale decided not to
publish that page it also decided not to
publish other illustrations one of which
was Gustav door A's 19th century
illustration of Muhammad in Hell was an
illustration for Dante's Inferno so they
went back on on a group yell went back
on an agreement for this because they
had canvassed various people nine or ten
people who said it would be dangerous
too dangerous to do that it would result
in violence so Yale preemptively
censored itself and says we will not
show this and as you know at the time
most American newspapers did not show
those cartoons on the grounds that they
wanted to protect religious feelings a
sentiment which has never appeared for
example when they show illustrate
illustrations which are insulting to
Christianity or perhaps other religions
or still on the publishers Random House
at the last minute rejected the
historical romance novel about
Muhammad's wife Aisha the jewel of
Medina by American writer sherry Jones
they said this was quote to protect the
safety of the author and anyone else
involved an English publisher was going
ahead until his house was
so more publishes self sensitive the
comedy show South Park refused to show
sorry the the comedy channel censored
one of its own programs it has a legal
right to do that of course that is the
comedy show cartoon show
South Park they wished the the episode
of South Park they've come into this a
lot they wanted to show an image of the
Muslim Prophet completely covered in a
pursuit though all you would see was a
birth they would say Muhammad's inside
him that was that was taken out they
could not show it the images of Buddha
of Moses of Jesus were of course left
this was no problem another one Molly
Norris a cartoonist for the Seattle
Weekly after the South Park episode said
we should have a everybody draw Muhammad
day you know just to show we're not
going to buckle under to this after
death threats he quickly withdrew the
suggestion the FBI advised her to go
into hiding she has given up her job
changed her name and gone into hiding
she's in the equivalent to a witness
protection program
for that statement in the United States
of America and in 2010 Jack
Zachary Cheshire Chesser a young convert
Islam pleaded guilty to threatening the
creators of South Park and was sentenced
to 25 years in prison or just one more
on October 3rd 2011 approximately 800
newspapers refused to run the
non-sequitur cartoon by Wiley Miller the
cartoon contained no depiction of
Muhammad but merely a bucolic scene with
the caption where's Muhammad The
Washington Post refused to cover that
it's not clear whether they said because
it was insulting to Muslims or they were
worried about safety but usually they
claim it's saying to do with religious
feelings but the same media are willing
to
carry insult to other religions I don't
know any newspaper or TV channel which
refused to carry advertising for say The
Da Vinci Code a book whose premises the
Christianity is false and the Church
engaged in mass murder to to hide that
fact so religious sensitivity is not
really the reason as British comedian
Ben Elton correctly said about the BBC
in a similar context says it was too
scared to allow jokes about Islam the
BBC will let you make Vika gags but they
will not let you make Imam gags they
might pretend that it you know something
to do with their moral sensibilities it
isn't it's because that's good so we
have this creeping danger within the
United States another concern is
relations Jean the current
administration and the Organization of
Islamic Cooperation seeking to shape
things shape speech about things Islamic
in his 2009 Cairo speech to the Muslim
world President Obama said that he would
and I quote fight against negative
stereotypes of Islam whenever they
appear
why again this was only of one religion
and why this would be understood to be
the job of the chief executive the of
the federal government was not clear but
this was taken to be you know policy of
the US government that we will fight
negative stereotypes of Islam in July of
last year secretaries in Istanbul
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
co-chaired with the OIC a high-level
meeting on combating religious
intolerance at that meeting co-chaired
with the OIC she invited the OIC to
Washington to exchange ideas on how the
US government should combat purported
neg negative stereotyping of Islam she
did not explain why the administration
is pardoning
with a religious organization which is
currently aggressively lobbying to
restrict freedom of speech in religion
and freedom of speech and religion
worldwide and many of whose members
ferociously we repress dissenting
religions and political views its
members include Iran who I've mentioned
Saudi Arabia who I've mentioned
Bangladesh Pakistan Egypt and others the
leading lights of this organization the
OIC has sought to pressure Western
governments for 20 years to restrict
speech about Islam
it's very charter committed to combat
defamation of Islam and its current
action plan calls for deterrent
punishments by all states to counter
purported Islamophobia they do not
define each of these terms but if we
study what they do at home it seems to
be clear what sort of things they would
like us to do as well the conference
that Hillary Clinton advertised while in
Istanbul was held in Washington DC
December 12th through 14 2011 it was
close to the public presentations
focused on America's deficiencies in its
treatment of Muslims note that there are
such deficiencies they stressed that the
u.s. needed to learn from other
delegations though which included
Pakistan Saudi Arabia and others Saudi
Arabia of course headquarters provides
the headquarters for the OIC and is a
country which bans churches repress his
Shiites publishes millions of textbooks
that teaches the Jews should be killed
and on the opening day of the conference
beheaded a woman for sorcery this was
one of the delegations the u.s. said it
needed to learn from on the matter of
Tolerance I should stress that Secretary
of State Clinton is emphasized in
Istanbul and also in talks around this
conference that she was not suggesting
any sort of legal control of speech but
learning to be simply learning to be
tolerant but if this is the case why
pick a partner whose very goal is legal
restrictions and who as it's
secretary-general said after this
conference was standard that the United
States was standing United with the OIC
on issues of speech so two large dangers
in the United States extra legal
violence or threat of violence leading
now to widespread self-censorship and
also government policies which is
seeking to control speech about Islam as
you probably know federal government
workers at least in the security areas
are not allowed to use certain words
which some Muslims have told them are
offensive to them these words include
words like Salafi which is a fairly
standard Muslim but it's there are many
Salafi organizations in the world and
they call themselves Salafis so they're
in fact names of certain organizations
in Egypt which US government employees
are not really allowed to say because
some people said that word is offensive
I've been I have I have Muslim
colleagues none of whom have ever seemed
to be offended by the use of that and
and other words so in conclusion one of
the main things I want to emphasize is
that the effects of this debate go far
beyond questions of religion narrowly
understood what they mean is that
governments are claiming Islamic
governments and Muslim organizations are
seeking to regulate religious and
ideological orthodoxy Islam shapes many
of its 1.6 billion followers in matters
of culture politics economic science
education of personally personal and
family life law and society as well as
what you could narrowly call religion
hence limits on criticism about or
within Islam forcibly silenced criticism
and debates on matters of culture
politics economics science education and
so forth they silenced criticism of
dominant religious ideas and political
power hence to the degree that the
Western world starts to fall into this
pattern certain areas of culture family
life economics politics would also be
off-limits to discussion the actress
Brigitte Bardot in in France has been
fined at least three times for her
criticism of Muslim slaughter practices
for halal meat I mean she said them in a
sort of pretty pointed manner but they
were in fact comments about a practice
rather than anything else so in the
Western world there's a tendency to
slide into the same sort of which very
broad-based restrictions as comedian
Rowan Atkinson who you might know as Mr
Bean who I know better as Blackadder as
a comedian Rowan Atkinson warns he's
been very outspoken on these matters
these restrictions produce a veneer of
Tolerance concealing a snake pit of
unheard and unchallenged views Norway
for example has very stringent hate
speech laws this did not prevent Anders
Behring Breivik
from slaughtering over 70 people because
of his antipathy to Islam indeed his
writing suggests that he engaged in that
violence because he believed he could
not otherwise be heard it was this a
horrific attention-getting device and in
the Muslim world radicals again cut down
debate on well most everything after
Salman Taseer
the Muslim government job the largest
province in Pakistan after he was
murdered in in January of last year for
opposing the country's blasphemy law he
was killed by one of his guards who said
he was a blasphemer for opposing the
blasphemy law so here you get the
ratchet effect
to criticize the law is illegal under
the law which you're criticizing and
indeed if you criticize that fact you
might so the ratchet effect goes on the
tadeas murderer was in fact convicted
but the judge who presided over the
trial in which he was convicted has had
to flee from Pakistan because of his
cooperation
you know seeking to punish someone who
killed a blasphemer would itself be
wrong so he cannot go there if you would
defend that judge you may find yourself
in the in that situation becomes very
like a Monty Python skit that you're not
allowed to mention anymore what it is
that you are dissenting from so and as
Sumant is here's daughter observed after
he was killed and then later on the only
Christian cabinet minister in Pakistan
Shabazz batty was killed
Casillas daughter said this is a message
to every liberal in Pakistan shut up or
be shot nasa abu zeid a muslim scholar
driven out of Egypt by Islamists say
that blasphemy accusations in the Muslim
world are key weapons in the
fundamentalist arsenal to prevent the
reform of Muslim societies and they will
confine the world's Muslim population to
a bleak colorless prison of socio
cultural and political conformity given
these tendencies within the Muslim world
President Obama and Secretary of State
Clinton should end US government
attempts with the UIC to shape free
discourse on Islam and instead clearly
declare that in open boisterous free
societies all religions and all views
are likely to be subject to credulity
criticism contradiction and calumny and
that the OIC and many others must learn
to accept
and protect these as the late Abdullah
Ram Wahid the former president of
Indonesia the world's largest Muslim
country former president of Naruto
Illuma the world's largest Muslim
organization of 40 to 50 million members
president Wahid wrote the forward to the
book silenced and in this he says
coercively applied blasphemy laws narrow
the bounds of acceptable discourse about
vast spheres of life literature science
and culture rather than encouraged
Muslim fundamentalists in their effort
to impose a spiritually void harsh and
monolithic understanding of Islam upon
the world
Western authorities should instead
firmly defend freedom of expression when
politics and religion are intertwined as
they necessarily are in debates about
blasphemy and insulting Islam then
without religious debate and critique
there can be no political debate and
critique America's founders at a time
when religious differences in this
country we're usually far more pervasive
intrusive volatile and sometimes
dangerous than they are now
prophetically forbade laws impeding the
free exercise of religion or abridging
freedom of speech or infringing the
freedom of the press their testimony and
their example is always needed but never
more so than it is time such as this
thank you very much